non-minimalists
how do you handle when you're enough is
different from your partners enough
here's the thing you're enough is always
going to be different from your partners
yeah even if you're bex and i
are so so similar and
even our aesthetic preferences are very
similar
but her idea of enough is different from
my idea of a nice sure she likes to go
camping
yes you don't like pretending you're
poor right
[Laughter]
i didn't have to pretend for 18 years
right
and another two years in my early 30s
no i i i've identified was enough for me
it's not about identifying what's enough
for your partner
yeah because it's a that's just a type
of comparison
yeah it's interesting because the saying
identify enough makes me feel like
and i know this isn't what you're saying
but it sounds like
oh i've identified enough so let me
write it out for you right now
yeah and let me or let me take a picture
of it for you sure and you can't really
identify enough that way
right i mean it's always going to be a
feeling it's always it's going to be a
it's like a sunset you can you you know
sunset when you see it but you can't
hold on to it
right right and by the way when at what
moment do you call a sunset a sunset
right
because is it is it three minutes before
it has
gone under the horizon maybe it's the
millisecond that it goes under the
horizon but then it's over
right it's only for i mean technically
if that's how you identify it then it
only happens for a millisecond
right and so so maybe expanding your
understanding of enough
but by realizing like a sunset there
isn't a moment the sunset starts
right it actually starts before it's a
sunset
yeah and so enough also starts by
realizing like oh i have more than
enough right now
and i'm going to get to an area that's
closer to enough by subtracting
i'm getting closer to the sunset but
then eventually i'll get to enough and
it may not be enough it may not be
enough anymore
and and and therefore it's it's starting
the process all over again but
it's my enough and recognizing
and then we have this four-step process
ryan and i have it's
an acronym we use terra t-a-r-a
when we look at someone else
understanding that you know bex
she has a different kind enough for me
and
and it as ryan says it's not a number of
things that can be a part of
of the essence that's the form and so
she likes plants more than me so the
form of her version enough is more
plants than what i would have in my own
house
right it's fine i'm not opposed to those
plants
in fact i go through the terra analogy
at first it was like okay i'll tolerate
those plants in the house
i don't want them okay fine but
wow these sure do enhance her experience
of life
and if her experience of life is
enhanced isn't my experience of life
enhanced so
i go from tolerance to the next big step
which is
acceptance i've accepted the fact like
oh wow yeah
she does get some joy out of this
this helps her in her life in some way
it is it enhances her life in some way
it serves a purpose in her life in some
way even if it doesn't a mind and now
all of a sudden serves a purpose in mind
by proxy and so i move on to that third
letter another big step
respect because it also serves a purpose
in my life it's a bit selfish to say
that but it's the truth
well now i can respect it because it
doesn't directly serve me
but it serves her and i respect her so i
get to respect
her relationship as long as she's not
doing something that's harming herself
or harming others
then of course there's a time to not
respect or tolerate if she started going
around
spewing racism online i'm not going to
tolerate
or appreciate right that which i
appreciate is the last step there
if we can truly get to that place where
it's not just respecting
their proclivities but wow you know what
that plan is kind of beautiful it's not
what i would have if i lived alone but
yeah that is beautiful bravo
bex man that's a much better place to be
in and
why do we have these stupid plants i
would never have these yeah
yeah i mean they're i'm thinking like a
worst case scenario
where you know um we've had people come
to our live events and they're like i'm
here because my partner's a hoarder
and i'm trying to talk them out out of
their stuff and
you know to a situation like that which
is again an extreme example
first and foremost um
there's some miscommunication between
you and your partner about what the
boundaries are for stuff
which is okay um but if it's that
hoarding type situation i mean there's
obviously something much deeper there
than just setting up some boundaries
yeah there's a mental illness with
hoarding
we did a whole hoarding episode about
this right right but
luckily i doubt uh stephanie here is in
that situation
yeah where her husband's order so or her
partner's order so
if your partner's things
are taking away from your what do you
want to call it tranquility
yeah your peace let's just say peace if
your partner's things are taking away
from your peace that is something you
have to bring to your partner
and it's it's not something that is
gonna
be solved overnight but you go to your
partner and you try to support them as
much as you can you tolerate them as
much as you can respect them
uh appreciate them as much as you can
but
ultimately there might have to be a
conversation where you're where you say
hey look i go out of my way to respect
you
and to love you and i want you to be
happy and i know that you want the same
thing for me you respect me you love me
you want me to be happy well
the amount of things that you that you
have it's really encroaching on my piece
and would you be willing to set up some
boundaries with me
so we can both get most of what we want
right
and and by the way it's in doing that
why i love
the way you're approaching ryan because
it's not hey your problem is causing me
problems because no it's not a problem
for them clearly
and even if it is a problem it's not up
to you to determine that it's
that it's a problem it has become a
problem for you now the problem isn't
the stuff
and you've identified that right what
you identified is oh the problem is the
disruption in my tranquility
right and in that disruption that
what is birthed out of that is a
difficult conversation a boundary that
may need to be set
or conversely it may be that like oh
this isn't actually a problem the plant
scenario i did with back says
i was able to get to a place where i
could appreciate that
and then all of a sudden the problem
dissipated and as soon as the problem
disappeared
as soon as it was eradicated yeah then i
didn't need a solution at all
i didn't even need a boundary right now
if she brought in seven more plants
then we're going to have to have a
conversation about this right because it
would be interrupting your tranquility
yes it would be interrupting your piece
yeah now we have a rule in our house
this is helpful to have a nice little
now you have to agree on this together
because you can't say here's our new
rule bex right
but the rule that we came up with
together after many conversations
and by the way that's why i love doing a
podcast with her it's kind of like when
we do how to love it's
it's almost us like talking through our
relationship
policies over and over and over like
trying to re
and it refines our policies in public or
into the public
and um anyway so the policy you have
with her is we don't bring anything new
into the house unless we've both
both agreed to bring it in now that's
restrictive to me
and it removes a little bit of my
freedom but it's how i maintain the
peace
i give up a little bit of freedom
because now i can't just well i'm gonna
bring you know what we really need a new
couch
because that that's not being a good
partner right
right i'm sorry it's not being a
considerate partner it's it's taking my
only my preferences into consideration
but if we're gonna bring something in
the house whether it's a blender or a
bed
or a new coat hanger then
it has to be agreed on by both of us now
we can do it in a way that isn't
combative hey what are you hey bex what
do you think of this co-hanger i was
thinking of replacing our coat hanger
you know we've had it for a long time
i don't really care for the design that
much what do you think of this one and
she might say is that really the best
use of armani that coat hanger is 40.
and you know what you're right but there
is an alternative it's 35
and you know we can talk about it in a
way where it's never judgmental
as soon as we judge we lose our ability
to love
yeah did you enjoy this video if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free